now back in front of the State Board of
Education starting high schoolers later
in the morning they've been discussing
it for years now now taking steps to put
it into place with what researchers say
is healthier for teenagers Ryan Matthey
showing us the reasoning the conflicts
and the likelihood of change
the morning Bell he
El rings at 7 10. a majority of CCSD
how early the science backs that up the
how to logistically start that Bell
later is what the state is figuring out
that is also a research proven we know
the research the research is very clear
the research is so strong so what's the
problem the challenge is adults that's
according to the Nevada State Board of
Education Thursday afternoon continuing
a years-long discussion of starting
teenagers just an hour or two later High
School junior Malia poblete says she
averages four hours of sleep a night
after balancing school extracurriculars
and a job we all will start doing
homework at like 10 o'clock at night and
then we have late nights and then when
we wake up it's all over again so it can
also decrease the violence and the
behavioral incidences therefore
increasing the safety and the positive
climate on our campuses but despite
those benefits I can't hire drivers
getting students to and from a later
start and end time poses logistical
problems for both Rural and Metro areas
alike some of the larger systems that
have this opportunity have a very robust
regional transportation from the
municipalities
that's not here in Nevada it joins a
list of other conflicts like teacher pay
staff retention parent work schedules
and after school programs the board
looking to the state legislature for
more funding and help what kind of
choices could we give to families what
what could we do
well the board agreed to Workshop this
topic it includes working with families
and other stakeholders over several
months but the board did not designate a
time or time frame for this to happen